[Music]
[Music]
today on stick to football we are gonna
have some fun going deep on the a NFC
East the NFC East that's what I wanted
to the NFC East drift classes ton of
intrigue Cowboys Eagles Redskins Giants
we're gonna break it all down Matt
Miller Melo and Connor Rodgers leave
those comments in the app we need draft
on draft question I'ma be honest we do
not have any right now we need your
draft on draft questions and if you want
to talk about mellow shirt you could do
that too you said we were gonna have a
fun show out with my fun shirt that's
what that's what we were doing mellow
looking very vacation ready I love it
today man right and you can only see
mellow if you watch this here in the
bleacher o4f she's got the backwards hat
on we'll have to join mulliner oh that
you've been a backwards hat guy he's got
the one airpot in like oh I have money I
have whatever we've been really like
going hard on Melo this week I'm sorry
we'll take it easy on Melo we are not
going to take it easy though on the NFC
East today breaking down all those
classes remember follow us in the bleach
report out post on Twitter a stick to
football and leave those comments and
questions below
look it to those the end of the show we
like to call it draft on draft Melo
looks like he needs a crown let's start
here because we would be celebrating our
guy Adam left Co maybe not so much after
the draft class that the reigning NFC
East champion Philadelphia Eagles had
Jalen rhaegar in the first round that
really surprised us then they came back
and took Jalen Hurd's
in the second round they ran out of
players named Jalen to draft in the
third but this is the class fellows Melo
give us your grade and what is your
takeaway from what the Eagles did look
I'm sorry to all the Eagles fans I am
and have some friends who are personally
Eagles fans this is an F grade for me I
don't see what they were doing here my
big takeaway from this thing is do they
even like Carson Wentz they gave him a
receiver who struggles to catch the ball
and then maybe drafted a guy that could
be his replacement you even hear the GM
going on air and talking about how you
know I really liked Russel Wilson and we
waited until the third round to take him
so we didn't wait to take this guy in
the second round I don't know if this is
going to be a tasting he'll package but
I'm not getting that vibe I'm getting
I don't know if Carson Wentz is gonna be
healthy by we might want to get a guy in
here who be our number two and maybe
eventually take over if we don't have
another contract for this thing in jail
and rhaegar you can see him here he's
catching the ball and I don't want to
keep pounding on this guy I think left
oh did it enough for all of us but he
can separate I don't know if he can
catch the ball and that is not gonna
play well in Philadelphia I think that's
what everyone's wondering right here I
was not that kind of this draft either I
gave it a c-minus now I do want to say I
really like Jalen hurts
I just don't know if I understand this
landing spot after paying carson wentz
all of that money and then when you look
at the other pics here they loaded up on
wide receivers I thought Jalen rhaegar
unfortunately was a reach maybe he'll
prove all of us wrong but I want to talk
about the player that I really do like
from this group and this present that it
prevented it from being in the DS or the
apps and that's capable Wallace from
Clemson I think when you look at a
player in the Eagles secondary that can
do a lot of different things that test
it very very well at the NFL Combine and
he can play in the slot he can play true
safety he comes downhill very very well
I thought the Eagles did a nice job
there so this Draft wasn't a total dud I
think they're gonna get a couple players
out of it I think back to what Melo said
you're wondering did they do a good
enough job building around Carson Wentz
and that's kind of where I have my
doubts right now they lost a ton in the
secondary Malcolm Jenkins has gone their
route to retooled that entire group and
on defense we didn't see them add a
whole lot what the hell is going on out
there that's my great big bit of the
Eagles I give them a D I just I can't
get on board with the value of Reger and
I do I hope I'm wrong I had him at 50
over on this draft class me to take him
in a 21 take him a 21 ahead of Justin
Jefferson that's a major problem for me
then to take Jalen hurts I like Jalen
hurts we were advocating for him to go
at 34 to the Indianapolis Colts nope
he goes to Lee Philadelphia Eagles where
I actually feel bad for Jalen like all
the stuff this guy's been through
Alabama Oklahoma to be doubted by me I
was doubting this guy a year ago now
it's your moment you're a second-round
pick and you go somewhere where there's
an established young high pig
quarterback I do feel badly for him and
maybe we see him doing what he did here
a lot of feeling special some tasting
he'll packages I did not understand
those first two picks
I like Davey on Taylor I like John
Hightower
they rebounded pretty well in the third
round but sudden you said Connor
to me I can't remember how we were
recording when you said this but you
have to wonder if the loss of people
like Joe Douglas like Andrew Barry has
Howie rosemond overthinking a little bit
so a degrade from myself guys let's move
on to a team though that they're not
gonna like this Eagles fans are gonna
like we come on here and it's like FC
minus D but how about those Dallas
Cowboys oh my lord
mellow Jerry Jones on his yacht just
making picks
knocking Grand Slams your thoughts on
the Cowboys I think Jerry needs to go to
the yacht every year because you look at
this drafted I think this is the best
class out of any team not just the NFC
East that we're looking at today I think
they filled a need with every one of
these positions you look at the ones
that are on the board right here I love
every single one of these guys even
Bradley and I the last pick that they
had before they took a quarterback and
that's a flyer in the seventh round but
all of these guys are going to
contribute on this team immediately
they've got some real talent here
obviously Seanie Liam the situation
where the Mauri Cooper's contract is
gonna be weird and it's gonna get real
weird after the 2021 season so I think
they have a guy that they can rely on
and be a number one receiver Amari
Cooper might even get knocked down to be
that number two guy and we'll see if
they're even paying him this is
definitely an a-plus for me the best
class out of every every team it's one
of my favorite drafts as well I think
when you look at what Wilma clay and the
Jones family did here they not only
solved needs but they got premium talent
and almost every single round it felt
like when you look at the value of this
draft
we love CD lamb city lamb was my number
one wide receiver I think what he adds
of this offense now you really can't
choose someone to double team you're
gonna have to I don't know who you give
the attention to you have to see Kelly
in the backfield you have a good
offensive line we know what Amari Cooper
and Michael gal could do now you add CV
lamb into the equation I think that's
really really exciting for this offense
but they kept attacking needs after that
getting to Ron digs in the second round
this is a team that needed a physical
press corner I just think and then you
go into the you know date three it looks
like to be honest right here this is
somebody that you look at in this class
and you go man he was a productive
starter for that Wisconsin offensive
line for a long time sure he was a
little banged up this year maybe didn't
look like
the guy we saw you know in his earlier
years at Wisconsin playing hurt but he's
somebody that can come in and be your
future starting Center down the line
that's just incredible value they top it
off with Bradley and I I had been
DiNucci as a draftable player in this
class coming out of jam you had the
quarterback position it just felt like
everything the Cowboys did made sense
while also getting good players in every
single round he has those mock draft
simulators on the internet where you can
like oh you do your your team's mock
there's no [ __ ] way that guy's gonna
be available nope he is Bradley and I
was available in the pit around Tyler
bearish balls to the fourth round sorry
I don't know they're supposed to curse
on this stick football life but
sorry yeah you can't teach an old dog
new tricks it did not feel like those
players should have been available where
they were even Reggie Robinson these
versatility athleticism to play corner
or safety he was one of the players when
Melo and I were doing draft 400 was like
where are we gonna rank him because we
have to put him somewhere
is he a corner is he a safety I think
we're eventually gonna see him play more
corner than safety right away I
absolutely love what they've done so far
in the strap it gets an a from me and
Jerry Jones like you said maybe our guy
needs to go to the yacht every year
because having that separation from from
everyone else at the star seem to work
very very well for the Dallas Cowboys do
not we're gaskey we gotta go ahead do
you think this draft put them as the
frontrunner in the AFC East the NFC East
because for me it clearly did oh yes
absolutely for me I do too I think with
CD lamb that offense is going to be very
difficult to stop and you look at what
the rest of the division did and they
struggling with the Cowboys anyway I
think getting dak some more tools and
like you were talking about with via
dish I think that he steps in right away
it is a very good center you have some
two very good guards playing next to you
you can kind of cover up some things
that Center I think this can be a very
good class and a very good office and
you were already good like honestly they
should have won the division last year
they kind of fell apart down the stretch
my biggest things like they're gonna
trust a lot of veterans on that d-line
you know doctor Ipoh you're bringing in
general McCoy Alden Smith and Randy
Gregory you hope you get something from
those guys so I think that's the key can
the linebacker stay healthy and the
d-line your trust on a lot of old dudes
to make plays opposite tank lawrence
alright today's show don't wait
let me back up don't forget drop your
draft on draft questions we need those
draft on draft duty in the show comments
questions whatever y'all want put it in
the stream right here but today's show
is sponsored by State Farm
State Farm offers home and auto
insurance so you're covered whether you
live in a new age bond like layer like
Kliff Kingsbury or a house made up of
discarded play looks like matt naggy
good news if you're listening Jerry
Jones State Farm does offer yacht
insurance we looked it up so to all the
stickey's listening from there 250
million dollar super yachts like good
neighbor State Farm will be there for
you even when you're deep into
international waters we have no word on
if State Farm covers table brady
randomly walking into your tampa bay
mansion thing in a spiral of which place
what they probably do Thank You State
Farm for sponsoring stick to football
five hundred fifty million dollar yacht
no way you guys are getting close to in
order to mess with you the whole time I
think I can do that Reed if you mess
with me well we will find out next week
for sure
alright next week we will be breaking
down the AFC North on Monday the NFC
North on Wednesday in the AFC south on
Thursday so that's the schedule for next
week guys but we have to continue with
the NFC East last year Connor put the L
grade out there for Dave gentlemen we
made fun of him drafting Daniel Jones we
made fun of him drafting another
defensive tackle Dave gentleman is the
gift that keeps on giving here at stick
to football that might he is but he gets
the come back old guy of the Year award
here the Giants knocked this one out of
the park here guys I really liked what
they did
I thought they started very strong I
thought the finish was a little weak
they just kept taking linebackers over
and over again but I give this class of
B plus I love Andrew Thomas plug and
play left tackle right tackle wherever
they want to plan Xavier McKinney one of
the smarter defensive backs in this
class can handle a lot of different
roles and then to get Darnay Holmes as
well later on I think was really really
helpful at the slot cornerback position
but you see what Andrew Thomas brings to
the table strong hands the ability to
mirror pass protectors high IQ permanent
team captain all those intangibles
that's something that Giants fans should
be excited about his sake won Barclay
has more room next year Daniel Jones is
held up right now what I wonder is you
know it felt
I don't really understand the strategy
here to be completely honest with you on
day three that was my only question this
would have been an A or an A+ class if
they could have got one more value
player but Gettleman he started off so
strong he ignored all of his old tactics
and then once again he just had to do it
he's like I need all of the linebackers
that are left on the board in day three
but overall a nice bounce-back for the
New York Giants
hey I've made that mistake - it's like
fantasy football drafts when you draft
four running backs oh my gosh now you
can play two of you whoops I think
that's what Dave gentlemen did the
linebackers we know he loves linebackers
I love their class though I'm gonna give
these guys an A - well I really think
that they did good I don't know how much
of a say Dave gentlemen had maybe he let
his computer folks do it but they did a
good job and getting Andrew Thomas in
there to protect you running back in
quarterback I think he can make a
difference he can change the way this
offense looks and then they just added a
lot of good depth pieces - Xavier
McKinney was one of my favorite safeties
in this whole class you look at what he
can do in coverage and against the run
he could have been safety won if it
weren't for Antoine Winfield who I think
was very good but I like this New York
Giants class I know we talk a lot of
crap on them I thought they did a very
good job this year much better than last
year I feel like Melo you have recently
retired as a teacher so you're gonna
understand this and I know we have a lot
of listeners who are in high school and
college they're gonna understand this
with Dave gentlemen we have to grade
this dude on a curve that's like Dave
gentlemen his drafts are not your normal
draft it's like okay you got the lowest
scores in class we'll just date for that
I'm gonna give you a b-minus on that one
alone Dave eg but I hated everything
they did after the second round I'm
gonna be completely honest I loved
Andrew Thomas is Xavier McKinney and we
took a pause round three starters like
okay all right guys figure some stuff
out maybe he read my seven or a mock
draft this year but then they got into
even round three I really felt like they
reached for Matt pert there at the gonna
play whether he plays left her right
tackle I feel like that was a reach you
know as you said Conor you drafted four
linebackers on day three and I know they
had a lot of picks but you at some point
like might want other positions that
linebacker and Darnay Holmes I know he's
feisty I know he's a fun corner I think
he's gonna be limited to the slot where
there is value there in the fourth round
he was
probably their best pick at a3 but
loading up on linebackers was just a
shock to me I'll say this I like their
undrafted free agent class better than I
liked their day 3 class so a b-minus for
me on the curve though speed this should
be clear on the curve all right
the Washington Redskins had nowhere to
go up they fire Jay Gruden midway
through last season they bring in Ron
Rivera they bring in Jack Del Rio
they've reorganized the front office
Connor it looks like maybe they're
starting to figure things out and how to
draft this team go back 2017 mostly
Alabama players in the first round but
that's kind of worked for them well it's
hard to completely fumble a draft your
guys when you have chase young on the
board when you pick so that was a great
start for Washington I think they got
the premier player of this class a guy
that'll be a double-digit sack player
very very early on in his career but I
think after that you know we like the
antonio gibson we dared to call him a
sleeper and then the guy goes you know
in the top 70 picks so i think when you
look at it you're not expecting him to
be a sleeper anymore you're expecting
him to be an actual contributor and then
Sadiq Charles in the third round I think
my concerns there are the teams I had
talked to had taken him off the board
they had you know off field concerns
going back to the suspension he had to
serve at LSU I think the talent is there
but what kind of player are you gonna
get and they did use a top of fourth
round pick on him so for the Redskins
here I gave it a c-plus I think chase
young is gonna be a star I think Gibson
can be a really nice pass catching
weapon and whether that's in the
backfield whether that's in the slot
Antonio Gandy golden for me projected as
a third or fourth receiver a good
blocker good size I don't know you know
if he brings you any more speed element
than Calvin Harmon already has on the
outside there are two guys that don't
run very very well and then really this
goes back to the giant strategy on day
three I just didn't really think they
got any players that I had valued at
those spots so the Redskins not a bad
draft once again I think they can get
two really good players out of this
thing but just not a great one when they
did have picks to work with later on
yeah and I'm gonna disagree with you
here Connor I'm gonna give these guys a
seat and that's only because they picked
up Chase young I do not like anything
else that they did in this draft I think
when you pull up that board you look at
this roster I wouldn't be surprised if
in two and three years we say wow nobody
the 20/20 classes left except for chase
yelling you even look at a guy like an
Tonio Gibson that night Oates in the
second round he might not be a running
back I know we haven't listened it was
early I had 33 carries in his college
career he might not be a running back he
might be a gadget guy that we get out in
the slot and say actually he can't
separate we got to cut him and move on
Sonique Charles is a very talented
tackle he might get cut he might get
himself into trouble before the NFL even
starts so you look at this roster I
really don't know what they did with
this class you got chase young so you
can't be a loser I'm giving it a C I
just don't like the rest of the picks
after number two overall yeah go third I
give it a C+ as well so I agree with
Connor on the grade but Melo what you
said it's fought on I didn't like
anything they did after chase young I
thought it was just cute like they've
reached Antonio Gibson might end up
being a great player he might also be
corduroy Patterson you know like you
have to get him in the right situations
for him to be explosive and Tonio Gainey
gogol we've never seen him play against
anyone good that Liberty you just didn't
do it and I know y'all are gonna be like
what the Senior Bowl those are practices
those aren't games it's not enough for
me to say yes he's gonna be dynamic and
dominant in the NFL so I do worry I
think Sadiq Charles could be a starting
left tackle if as you guys alluded to
six-game suspension this season for
violation of team rules that's an issue
in the NFL so a lot of boomer bus type
prospects from Washington and this
year's draft that is why they get the C+
for me what gets an a-plus for me every
time I'll watch it that is call or
nothing we have a special Jerry Jones
edition hopefully we see the yacht
called that called Dakota Prescott hello
mr. Jones hey bud just gone for our
daily contract negotiation how about
four years twenty million a year and
I'll throw in a half a dozen oil rigs I
want 35 million dollars a year
oh you're serious
I deserve it sir I'm a great leader it's
fine okay how about 25 million and I'll
let you add a fifth play in the Mike
McCarthy's flavor are you having another
hootenanny uh no I made this I'm so sure
myself
good we need to be socially distant okay
here
me and Zeke what's up Jerry hey Zeke
tell Jack that we want him on the team
hey Doc we want you on the team
he paid Zeke you paid him Ari I need to
get what's mine oh no sir you're old
you're just imagine things again I do
sometimes think of tsunamis but it makes
me so happy it's a different time now
Jared Goff got thirty three and a half
million I'm better than him right right
okay maybe I can convince Amaro to give
me back some 100 million how about 36
mill and I about you to my next illegal
party I hope you guys never been in that
Stadium you can't look at the field but
you just you sitting just stare it's
like being at mercedes-benz in Atlanta
you watch the game on the big TV the
Jerry fell off up so I mean that's
perfect for watching football football's
the TV sports absolutely is
we're not Hawking any tickets today so
Mello can say that that is TV super all
right we do have draft on draft
questions don't forget we will be back
here next week Monday Wednesday Thursday
at 5 p.m. Eastern Time breaking down the
AFC North the NFC North and the AFC
South let's get to these draft on draft
questions though during call they're
nothing I cheated and read the questions
and put my answers there to mellow like
got mad at me midway through the clips
all my answer so it's like oh I'll read
the question all right I know I'm
answering and I'd say that you just pop
in our little Doc and you answered sorry
I'm faster than you
oh my gosh all right fly eagles fly oh
three needs some good news in its life
who's the best day three player in the
NFC East I took this to mean from the
2020 class it's open to interpretation I
think the answer is Bradley and I being
drafted in the last pick in the fifth
round we talked about it during the BR
gridiron Draft special that we did
Connor he fell in the draft because
teams just did not think he was athletic
enough after a bad combine I think the
tape is there so Bradley and I
especially going to Dallas that was a
really really good spot really good fit
for him I think he'll be an impact
player
I love Bradley and I and he was gonna be
the guy that I put up there in the fit
in Dallas I think is perfect since I'm
gonna have to choose a different player
here I'm gonna go with Dallas as well
though I'm taking Tyler beer dish I
really think that he can slide in and be
a very impactful center if not only like
a Pro Bowl level you have a very good
all
and sublime there if he can stay healthy
of Zeke Elliott running behind you
that's gonna make you look better you
have dak at quarterback I think this
guy's in the perfect position to succeed
and taking over a fellow Wisconsin guy I
really like to fit their own via dish
I'm gonna make our Eagles fan
you know beYOU are happy here I do think
it's cave on Wallace I wouldn't be
surprised if Bradley and I as a great
season maybe be if this starts I think
when you look at all the different roles
and the athleticism that cave on Wallace
has he's somebody that can make a
difference as the Eagles do have some
turnover in their secondary so I thought
that was a really good day three pick
another guy that has all the talent in
the world we keep saying it to be the
best day three pick in this division is
Sadiq Charles we just don't know what
version of him is going to show up but
we know that Washington team needs help
on the offensive line there's gonna be
opportunity for him if he could just
keep his head focused yeah and I gotta
shut up my god John Hightower from Boise
State fifth round pick by those
Philadelphia Eagles I actually like him
Bennett Jalen Rhaegar's a better
prospect I like John Hightower better
for that team so we'll see what happens
there second question from Wyatt charter
why it gets back-to-back questions this
week appreciate him
what's your fate what's your least
favorite prospect to team fit almost
went favorite I am jumping in with I
think the answer for all three of us you
guys said surprise me if not Jalen hurts
to the Philadelphia Eagles is without a
doubt my least favorite bit
I wanted to see Jalen Hurd's go
somewhere and be a starter that's why I
thought the Chargers in round 2 if they
didn't go quarterback at six the Colts
at 34 the Buccaneers maybe like the
Steelers at 49 there were so many fits
for Jalen Hurd's this was not one of
them so I feel badly for him well I
guess we'll see how it plays out but I
did not think he would land here yeah I
don't like to fit for hurt so I wanted
to see him go to a team where maybe
there were some questions at quarterback
where he could actually compete for a
job and I still I don't know what the
role is gonna be for him in Philadelphia
I'm gonna go with another quarterback
though a Jake from is a guy that we've
talked about a lot with the State Farm
rat ad reads but I just don't understand
why you have two totally different
quarterbacks and I don't feel like they
were in a position where they had to
come in and draft a quarterback I think
they could have found a guy that was a
veteran that could have backed up Josh
Allen and
you get a quarterback that's completely
different from him I don't know how him
and Josh Allen could run the same
playbook so I have a lot of questions
with that fit yeah I don't doubt it at
all I think I would if I had to get away
from the Jalen Hertz one because there's
football fans we want to watch him
obviously play I think it would be
Azra Cleveland going to the Vikings I
think when I look at that pick I thought
Cleveland was not a guy that is ready to
play right away and if you draft him
there feels like the expectations are
that he's gonna have reps on the field
to earn a starting job now maybe he
surprises us but it would really really
shock me if the play strength is there
to come in and be a productive starter I
thought he could have went somewhere
where he was given at least a year or
two to develop hi boys last question
from G doozy huge Cowboys fan I've been
blaming Jason Garrett for a while now do
you think he was the problem or did the
Cowboys just always underperform well G
do Z as a Niners fan I can tell you they
don't always underperform because those
nineties teams were amazing I think
Jason Garrett's message got stale I
think this got old after a while
then you need somebody to clean [ __ ] I
think that happens all the time you look
at Ron Rivera and Carolina he was a very
good coach every once in a while you
just need somebody else to come in there
it's not that they did a bad job I think
Jason Garrett was just in that locker
room for a little bit too long and like
you said message got stale but I guess
you have to play blame to somebody so
yeah I think Jason Garrett wasn't able
to get those guys going every Sunday I
think getting a new face in that locker
room I would be very surprised that the
Cowboys didn't win this division this
year yeah I agree it seems like they
needed new energy actually I'm banking
on a pretty big year a pretty big
bounce-back year in his first year as
the coach the Cowboys for Mike McCarthy
I think the offense is gonna be fun to
watch I think he was very vocal when he
took the year off and said listen I need
to step away I need to dive into
analytics I need to dive into where
football is going on the offensive side
of the ball and really retailer my
scheme so I think Dallas is a team to
watch this year all the weapons are
there you have a franchise quarterback
you have a top-flight running back you
have a really really good offensive line
that has built chemistry over the years
even if they do have to start a new
center there is chemistry amongst that
unit so I think when you look at
McCarthy over there I do think this was
the right call I think it'll bring in
some fresh perspective over there
curious to see how they get all these
weapons involved likewise psyche leaves
the Packers where they've never drafted
a first round receiver first thing he
does takes a receiver trap CD lamp so he
he's already proven that he learned from
his mistakes in green base we got to get
McCarthy credit there lots of love for
our guy mellow shirt in the comments
you're gonna only see this if you watch
in the BR app or on YouTube after we do
it live Melo do you have a Chiefs
Hawaiian shirt ready for Monday not yet
not yet all right
Melo an ad read rockin those not it's me
it's Amy Reed it's Ron Rivera I'm in
good company we're the Hawaiian shirt
trio there you go can't wait for the
season to start so we can see those guys
together follow us on twitter at NFL
draft scale at mellow and at Conner Rick
Jay Rogers gafsa bellows and stick to
football and of course right here in the
app that's where you get show updates as
well as just the nonsense that we all
three come up with Monday Wednesday
Thursday next week 5 p.m. Eastern we'll
be back right here in your BR app
[Music]